[موسيقى]
تاثير الحرب على قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
رئيسي احتل الروس محطه الطاقه النوويه
زابوريتش وهي الاكبر في القاره الاوروبيه
حيث تمتلك سته منفعلات نوويه من القوه
الاولى وهذه المحطه تشكل ربع اي 25% من
قدره اوكرانيا على توليد الطاقه قبل الحرب
الابتزاز النووي لاوروبا والعالم ياتي عبر
احتلال هذه المنشاه النوويه اضافه الى
التهديد بالصواريخ النوويه فضلا عن ان
الضربات بالمسيرات على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه دمرت نحو خمسه جيجا فولت من القدره
الاوكرانيه للطاقه اضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير
الشبكات الطاقه بالطبع فقدت اوكرانيا من
40 الى 50% من قدرتها على توليد الطاقه
لكن رغم ذلك بدعم من شركائنا تم مولدات
ومعدات جديده لذلك كنا قادرين على اجتياز
هذا الشتاء الصعب
[موسيقى]
هذا العام تحتاج اوكرانيا الى 47 مليار
دولار للتعافي السريع هذا مبلغ كبير
للغايه حتى اليوم لدينا دعم من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بمبلغ 18 مليار دولار من
البرنامج المالي ودول مجموعه السبع اضافه
الى اننا نعمل مع برنامج صندوق النقد
الدولي بالطبع يجب ان يصبح برنامج صندوق
النقد الدولي بمثابه دعامه هيكليه للدعم
الطويل الاجل لانه نوع من المؤشرات
وبرنامج صندوق النقد الدولي هو مؤشر على
استقرار البلد من حيث التنميه الاقتصاد
الكلي واستقرار الظروف العاديه له اهميه
كبيره في اقتصادنا فنحن نعمل معهم بنشاط
كشركاء وانا مقتنع باهميه العمل مع
شركائنا
[موسيقى]